a hostage taker is dead after police
moved in on him in the Eastern German
city of Dresden
his two hostages escaped unhurt police
say the suspect suffered from mental
illness and earlier had killed his
mother
[Music]
hundreds of officers took part in the
police operation which spanned several
hours and several locations before
ending here at this shopping mall in
central Dresden after phone negotiations
failed to convince the suspect to
surrender himself and the woman and
child he had taken hostage police
stormed the shopping center
specifically we heard what sounded like
gunshots and that's why we carried out
this emergency Advance slamming the
front door and facing the arm
perpetrator inside in the end we fired
on the suspect he later died as a result
of those injuries
police say nobody else was harmed during
the operation earlier in the morning the
suspect's 62 year old mother was found
dead in an apartment outside the city
police say her death is linked to her
son's Rampage which included an attempt
to break into a local radio station
before heading to the mall at about 9
A.M police described the 40 year old as
mentally unstable they're investigating
the circumstances surrounding his
mother's murder and the hostage taking